[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here from
google i o 2017
and io is definitely a a little bit
different every year but it's a
developer conference for people who use
google software and for all the
developers of apps that run on that
software so while there is no new
hardware there's no pixel 2 or anything
crazy like that happening here there is
a lot of googly software a lot of
machine learning and image recognition
and all that fun stuff that will
eventually make it into the devices that
we have now so there's definitely some
stuff to pay attention to this is my top
five announcements from google i o 2017.
so number one is google lens and i had a
feeling something like this would make a
comeback so so much of like what i said
the stuff at this conference is stuff
like computer vision and machine
learning and image recognition and this
is a perfect example of a culmination of
all of that so google lens is a new
capability that will start showing up in
assistant and photos and others that'll
let you point your camera at an object
and get more information about that
object now if that sounds familiar
that's because it is we've had stuff
like google goggles from way back in
2010 believe it or not and then stuff in
between like bixby etc but the
technology has gotten a lot better since
2010 so this is actually almost a
completely different product now google
lens and assistant is so good you can
point it out a flower and it'll tell you
not only that it's a flower but what
kind of flower it is or if you're
walking down the street and point lens
at a restaurant since google maps knows
where you are image recognition is
pretty easy to overlay info about the
place you're looking at and even more
awesome you can point lens at the bottom
of a router that sticker you know where
it says the username and the password
and the ssn and it'll log you in instead
of having to type it all out so google
lens looks awesome and while it's not
out right now i think if it ends up
looking and working as well as it did in
those videos then it should be pretty
dope so number two is google assistant
and first things first google assistant
is now available on the iphone so it's
it's on my iphone i got it in the app
store you can get it too right now and
this is the exact same assistant it
works the exact same way as it does on
my pixel or any other android phone so
that's awesome and there's even some
iphone specific optimization since
obviously you can't hold down the home
button to get to it that's where siri is
so you make a widget to put right next
to your home screen to launch the
assistant to get right to talking to it
you can scroll up to see your history of
things you've asked for in the past
which is cool and then you can also even
type questions to it so if you're in a
quiet place and you don't have the space
to ask things out loud to it you can
type what you want to know and hit send
and it'll answer hopefully that's coming
to the android version soon and then the
other news is now google assistant will
hopefully be in way more places really
soon thanks to the sdk becoming
available to third-party developers so
the example they used on stage was
literally pulling up google assistant
and telling it you just want some panera
and instead of it telling you what
panera is near you it actually pulls up
the menu lets you pick exactly what you
want to eat and orders delivery so
that's pretty awesome so we're starting
to see google assistant in a lot more
places it went from being this pixel
only thing to being an android only
thing to being much more widely
available and that's kind of what google
i o is all about so number three is
android o and you're probably
you're probably familiar with android o
because i already did a video about it
you probably watched my top five
features on android o video if you
haven't i'll link that below that's
where a lot of the main stuff is but at
i o they've announced that it's
graduated from a developer preview to a
beta so now it's available in the beta
channel anyone with a pixel or a nexus
can download it and you can check out a
couple of new features that have also
made it to this version one thing i
really like is the picture-in-picture
mode which is sort of like while you're
doing one thing you can continue doing
that in the background and move to
another thing and just hit the home
button to continue multitasking you get
a floating window that continues your
background task so while you're watching
a youtube video you can hit home and
open up a notes app and start taking
notes while the video plays and when
you're done you can literally just swipe
it away there's also something called
notification dots kind of like something
you would see in ios where you have
those little badges for notification
icons notification dots are the same way
they'll indicate on an app on your home
screen where you have notifications so
to check that notification you can
either pull down in the tray like normal
or you can actually long press that app
icon on the home screen to look at it
and that will give you the same
information so android is coming along
pretty nicely we should see the full
final version of it and probably get a
name for it uh sometime this summer but
it's got a couple other little features
like improved autofill uh better looking
emojis that are redesigned all kinds of
faster boot times things like that so
but if you want to see the full five
best new features about android of
course you should watch that video so
number four is google photos so you may
or may not use this but the improvements
to it in the last year have gotten
really good and they're pretty much all
in the space of machine learning and ai
so it already organizes your photos just
by things that's recognized in them it
recognizes the faces the locations
places you took them the landmarks in
the background all sorts of things like
that now it's just making that
information more available to you so
there's something called suggested
sharing where it recognizes faces in
your photos and essentially suggests
that you share those photos with the
people that are in them there's also
shared libraries which can automatically
share every photo you take of your kids
for example with your partner and
possibly the coolest one is some
automatic photo manipulation now that
this isn't just like the little filters
it adds to your photo apparently if this
works well it'll let you literally
remove obstructions from the front of
the photo the example they showed on
stage was incredible i hope it works
that well but again we have to see all
right so number five last but not least
is google home again you may or may not
have one of these but it's getting some
improvements that are improving it well
too one is called proactive assistance
so you know how google now sometimes
gives you little notifications telling
you there's a traffic incident on your
normal route or something that it kind
of thinks you might want to know ahead
of time well now google home will also
be able to do that but since it doesn't
have a display it'll do that with the
lights on the top so now when you see it
lighting up by itself you can just ask
what's up and it'll tell you that news
there's also hands-free calling coming
to google home which i think is pretty
awesome and also long overdue and i can
even start showing responses to
questions that require a visual response
on your tv or your phone so before it
wouldn't make sense to ask google home a
question like show me my calendar
because there's no display obviously but
now since it's smart enough to connect
your tv or your phone it will show that
response on a device with the display
which is pretty convenient so that's
pretty much it thank you for watching
our little recap of google i o 2017 feel
free to share this with other people who
you think might want to know what was
announced today and don't want to watch
the two-hour keynote or you can watch
the two-hour keynote i'll link that
below as well but uh that's pretty much
it thank you for watching and i'll talk
to you guys in the next one
peace
all right i want to ask you both
what was you've seen like the entire day
one keynote now you have a bunch of new
announcements what was your favorite new
thing from io so far you start favorite
favorite thing are you sure yeah
uh
for me it's google lens yeah uh you know
i love the fact that you know we today
see a lot of stuff and that's how humans
take in a lot of information so to be
able to point things that
stuff you're interested in yeah i'm
finding more about it i think it's
pretty cool yeah
i think android go you know i have two
actually one consumer one and one
developer one is that cheating that's
good
yeah it's kind of cheating do what i
want okay cool android go you know it's
it's a new configuration of android for
the one game or less crowd i think it's
important you know and we really want to
make that experience great and then
kotlin which is a developer thing it's a
new language
did you hear the crowd that was nice
that was the loudest one
this is a developer conference so you
get to get the crowd going with it
absolutely those are my favorites
awesome